nathan of aldi eight wins four losses he
is the red sox wins leader
a little delay there but whit
held his stance
kept his hands back and singles to
center to begin the game
santana lines one to right
whit makes the turn and holds
and the royals have two on with one out
they have scored first in each game of
the series so far
2-2 swing animus with the split he's
struck him out and strands two
who [ __ ] two and three with a 447 era
his seventh start sox have won six in a
row and at 50 and 31 are in sole
possession of the american league's best
record here is the surging [ __ ]
hernandez driven to deep left field is
it high enough it is
home run kiki
to lead off the first and it's one
nothing red sox as we go to the bottom
half of the fourth inning and the red
sox with a one nothing lead jd martinez
will lead things off high fly ball well
struck that one's going to carry that's
a deep drive back it goes and she's gone
jd martinez with number 17. red sox on
top two to nothing
that's tag for base hit
between dozier and lopez
renfro up to second red sox trying to
get something started here with two down
so it's renfro and gonzalez on
lunges at that one it's a high fly ball
pretty well hit racing back dyson racing
back leaps he cannot get it
that ball is gone
how about danny
santana like no stride there
and he cracks one into the bullpen
and the red sox are on top five to
nothing one man gone
and that drills if he gets hit by the
pitch
fastball in
no chance to get out of the way and
that's going to load the bases though
they are all loaded up for raphael
denver's he's hitting in a double play
and he's also grounded out the second
and a live shot left center field for a
base hit rodulgo will score
martinez charging around he will score
and it is seven to nothing boston and
now 66 runs batted in for raphael now
you know you
if you brought me out damage to that
situation to get the bases loaded it was
the person that comes to mind a grand
slam home run right no he just takes
what they give him and they give him a
fastball away and he goes away with it
perfect swing
perfect result drive in two more runs
give the red sox the comfortable lead
that's just nice hitting by devis
and that's going to be ball four so the
red sox have loaded the bases again
2-2 little lob shot popped up
lands on the dirt and how about that
that's going to drive in a run you've
got to be kidding and the red sox lead
at eight to nothing four rbis now for
santana he barely made contact and he
popped it up on the infield well if that
doesn't draw a laugh with some smiles i
don't know what will because
this is a grown man that hit this
i mean
look at this thing
it's just popped up in the infield and
drops in he can't believe it as he's
running down the first base they're back
in the you know they're playing the
second baseman d but i mean
my goodness
when you hide your heart right
boy things are going well things are
going well
and that's going to be a block and here
comes another run
that will send renfro home to make it
nine to nothing as santana box
and they step off the rubble with the
wrong foot
wow this one's turning into a laugher
let's see what happens here
i just dropped the baseball that's a
buck
boy this is
rather ugly
and a swing at him is to put away
santana that that has worked really well
for him yeah that's been very effective
for him this afternoon got a couple of
strikeouts with him swing and a miss
slider 86 miles an hour to strike him
out now nate's got everything going on
now the fastball the slide or the split
nasty down below the knees
bounding ball how about this right at
the only man on the left side debors to
gun and get him one two three they go
[Music]
rips that one past the outstretched
glove of o'hern down the line
a couple of good swings here for verdugo
today starting to get it going again
hot smash pass dozier down the line to
the track up against the wall martinez
taking off for third
throw comes in there but too late
xander bogart's down to second one two
swinging there's a shot
deep right oh he crushed it that ball's
gone
three run homer for raffi number 20.
that was a rocket
the red sox blow this one wide wide open
and marwing gonzalez to lead things off
against scott barlow
next man up
bounding ball through for a base hit or
hearn dove could not reach it
marwin continues to swing the bet very
well two hits today
2-2 a little lob shot again down into
right field
gonzalez around into third a base hit
for connor wong his second major league
hit and they're on the corners
the one from barlow a swing at a high
fly ball into left
oliveras getting underneath
harwin gonzalez can tag as the throw
comes into third and the red sox grab
another run
chavis with the rbi
and the red sox lead it 13 to nothing
rips that one into right field for a
base hit
hit number three today for rafi
bottom of the eighth inning he'll sting
that one into left center field down for
a base hit evers trots up to second and
stops there
hits keep on coming for the sox
swing and that one driven toward the
alley dropping dropping it's down for a
hit
so there couldn't get it devers romps in
he scores
another hit for marwyn gonzalez a
three-hit game and the red sox lead it
14 to nothing there's a high twisting
fly ball to left oliver's back's gonna
play it off the green
another run is in renfrow scores
red sox leading at 15 to nothing on the
double santana's had a big big day he's
driven in five and bought two strikes
one of the great catches in red sox
history swinging a miss by perez he's
gone and the red sox are one out away
royals about to taste a ninth
consecutive loss swung on and missed
that's how it ends red sox and a blowout
15-1 as they rip off seven in a row